Transcription: freddy crozilhac
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Nous sommes 600 ce soir
dans cette salle.
Statistiquement,
il y a 300 personnes stressées
parmi nous.
Si c'est pas vous,
c'est votre voisin.
Moi aussi j'ai été stressée,
très stressée,
et très anxieuse.
Je voudrais vous raconter
comment aujourd'hui,
je ne le suis plus.
Avec l'aide de mes images.
Au moment où j'ai pris cette photographie,
je perdais tous mes repères.
J'avais coché toutes les cases
de ma liste,
cette liste qu'on se fait,
avec des buts à atteindre,
avant tel ou tel âge.
Pour moi
c'était...
mariage, enfants, maison,
comme dans le conte de fées.
Pourtant,
je n'étais pas cette femme épanouie,
cette mère comblée,
comme j'avais prévu.
Et quand je rentrais chez moi,
j'étouffais dans ma maison
de conte de fées.
Mon couple était percuté
par un jumbo jet
avec écrit « divorce » dessus.
C'était pour moi comme
l'effondrement des tours jumelles.
J'étais dans MA catastrophe planétaire.
Et c'est là,
quelques semaines avant mes 40 ans,
alors que ma vie était en plein chaos,
qu'est arrivé le bug.
Je suis dans le cabinet d'un médecin
et cet homme m'annonce
que j'ai un cancer,
un cancer du sein.
Il m'explique
que tout d'abord il va m'opérer,
pour m'enlever un sein.
Et qu'ensuite j'aurai des traitements,
je perdrai peut-être mes cheveux.
Et puis il me fait
un arrêt de travail,
il dit que ça peut durer longtemps,
plusieurs années.
Mon cerveau est déjà tellement plein
de problèmes à régler
et d'incertitudes.
Là, je me sens comme un lapin
dans les phares d'une voiture.
Je suis incapable de bouger,
de réfléchir,
je suis totalement terrorisée.
Il faut savoir que quand j'étais enfant,
j'ai perdu deux de mes grands-parents,
et trois oncles et tantes
de cancer fulgurant.
J'ai grandi avec ces gens,
j'étais proche d'eux,
leur disparition m'a
profondément marquée.
Et là c'est mon tour.
Pour moi, avoir un cancer,
ça voulait dire mourir,
comme eux.
A partir de ce moment-là,
j'ai été tout le temps angoissée.
Même respirer est devenu difficile
tant j'étais oppressée.
J'étais tout le temps ce lapin
dans les phares de la voiture,
qui voit sa mort arriver.
Et je pensais tout le temps à mes enfants.
Mes enfants,
c'est ce que j'aimais de ma vie.
J'aimais entendre leurs rires,
les regarder jouer,
faire des bêtises, bien sûr.
A partir de ce jour-là,
quand je regardais mes enfants,
je voyais des orphelins.
Le médecin avait dit aussi :
« Votre pronostic est favorable. »
Pronostic..
C'est un terme de courses hippiques.
Les médecins l'utilisent
pour vous expliquer,
que vous n'allez peut-être pas mourir,
mais qu'ils n'en sont pas certains.
J'ai pensé que si j'étais
un cheval de course,
cet homme miserait peut-être sur moi.
Et je crois qu'il a voulu me rassurer,
lorsqu'il ajouté : « Votre vie ne sera
plus jamais comme avant. »
J'aimais pas ma vie avant,
alors j'ai préféré comprendre
qu'elle serait mieux,
et ça m'a aidée
pendant les opérations,
pendant les chimios,
et la radiothérapie,
et quand j'ai perdu mes cheveux.
C'était comme la lumière
au bout du tunnel.
Un long tunnel
qui a duré trois ans.
Et pour tenir bon malgré l'anxiété
et les effets secondaires
des traitements,
j'ai cherché des solutions
pour que mes enfants
aient une mère vivante,
mais une mère vivante et debout.
Parce que sincèrement,
certains jours,
je n'arrivais pas à me lever.
Une amie m'a amenée marcher.
J'aimais pas du tout ça, marcher.
A la limite à New York pour aller faire
les expos, du shopping, pourquoi pas ?
Mais bon, elle avait eu une bonne idée,
elle a bien fait d'insister.
Ça m'a fait du bien tout de suite.
Etre dans la nature, me vider la tête,
et sentir mon corps fatigué,
en action
me réconfortait.
J'ai pris l'habitude d'aller au parc
près de chez moi régulièrement.
Mais bon, au bout de 50 tours de parc,
il fallait quand même
que je rentre à la maison.
Et donc je suis allée voir un psy,
des thérapeutes,
j'ai fait de l'homéopathie,
de l’acupuncture,
j'ai même vu un chaman.
J'ai lu plein de livres
pour me renseigner,
pour comprendre ce qui m'arrivait.
J'ai lu « Guérir »
de David Servan-Schreiber.
J'y ai trouvé beaucoup d'infos,
et j'y ai découvert les recherches des
neurosciences sur le stress et l'anxiété.
Et ça m'a vraiment aidée
de comprendre ce que je vivais,
et de savoir que d'autres gens
le vivaient aussi.
Je me suis sentie moins impuissante.
Et j'ai essayé...
l'hypnose,
j'ai fait des séances d'EMDR,
j'ai utilisé des techniques
de relaxation profonde
pour me préparer aux opérations pour
la reconstruction de mon sein ensuite.
Et j'ai commencé à faire de la méditation.
Ce sont ces méthodes
qui m'ont inspiré
le projet Forces Naturelles.
J'ai voulu à travers ce projet
partager les bienfaits.
qu'elles m'apportaient
Et puis c'était important pour moi
de m'exprimer artistiquement.
Mon travail artistique
m'a beaucoup aidée
pendant cette période,
ça m'a donné beaucoup de force.
Au bout de trois ans,
il a fallu que je retourne au travail.
L'arrêt maladie était terminé
et comme je ne pouvais plus faire
le métier que je faisais avant,
j'ai fait une reconversion
professionnelle.
J'allais dire une reconstruction,
mais ça c'était déjà fait.
J'ai fait une reconversion
professionnelle,
je voulais rebondir
dans le monde du travail,
après m'être traînée dans les couloirs
de la clinique pendant trois ans.
Alors j'ai fait une formation,
à plein temps.
Avec des stages en entreprise,
et un mémoire de 40 pages à rendre.
Le problème, c'est que de la mémoire,
je n'en avais plus.
Et puis, après quatre ans de lutte,
je saturais.
En fait j'ai fait un burn-out
avant la fin de la formation.
Et de toute façon, je n'en pouvais plus
de chercher des solutions.
J'étais au bout du rouleau,
et je n'avais plus d'énergie.
Alors je n'ai pas eu le choix.
Cet été-là,
l'été de mon burn-out,
j'ai appris la patience,
j'ai appris à être patiente.
J'ai accepté
que ça prendrait beaucoup
plus de temps que je ne le pensais,
de me remettre --
de me rétablir.
Et beaucoup plus de temps
que je ne le voulais,
de reprendre une vie normale,
avec un métier,
avec un travail.
Et puis,
j'ai accepté de vivre avec le doute,
avec le fait de ne pas savoir
de quoi mon avenir serait fait.
J'ai dit adieu aux listes
inscrites dans le marbre.
Je me suis faite à l'idée que vivre,
c'est être comme
un funambule sur son fil.
Ne pas avoir de certitudes,
c'est difficile n'est-ce pas ?
Ça fait peur.
Je voudrais vous raconter
l'histoire du « K ».
C'est un récit de Dino Buzzati
que j'ai lu quand j'étais adolescente
et que j'aime beaucoup.
Il m'a suivie toute ma vie.
Et je crois que je l'ai compris
cet été-là véritablement.
C'est l'histoire d'un homme
qui toute sa vie est poursuivi
par un monstre.
Et toute sa vie, il le fuit
jusqu'à ce que très vieux,
il se décide à l'affronter.
Il n'a plus rien à perdre,
il se prépare à mourir.
Il s'approche de la bête,
et le monstre
ouvre sa gueule toute grande.
Et sur sa langue,
il lui tend
une magnifique perle qu'il lui offre
avant de disparaître.
Moi aussi j'ai eu un cadeau cet été-là.
J'ai compris que
les obstacles sur ma route
n'étaient là que pour donner corps
à toutes les possibilités
que m'offre la vie.
Sur cette image,
ce ne sont pas les arbres
qu'il faut regarder,
mais tous les chemins entre eux.
Tellement de possibilités,
tellement d'avenir.
C'est à ce moment-là
que j'ai entendu parler
du travail d'un homme américain
qui depuis trente ans aide
les malades du cancer
à gérer leur anxiété,
leur stress,
et aussi la douleur.
Cet homme s'appelle John Kabat-Zinn.
Il a créé le programme de réduction
du stress par la pleine conscience.
J'ai fait ce programme
et pendant deux mois,
quarante minutes tous les jours,
je me suis entraîné à juste
observer mes pensées,
à sentir mes sensations,
mes émotions,
et à les laisser passer
en revenant sur ma respiration.
A l’hôpital Sainte-Anne à Paris,
cette méthode a permis de réduire
de moitié les rechutes dépressives
des malades.
Ça marche.
Ça a été pour moi
une véritable rééducation à la vie,
jusque dans les petites choses
du quotidien :
marcher dans la rue, l'esprit libre,
même pour venir à Bobino
parler sur scène.
Manger,
faire la cuisine,
en prenant plaisir
à toutes les sensations.
Parler à quelqu'un
en étant vraiment présente.
Mes enfants apprécient beaucoup.
Comme tout le monde,
j'ai des problèmes,
mais aujourd'hui
je ne panique plus.
Je garde mon énergie
pour les gérer.
Comme il y a quelques temps,
quand mon fils Henry s'est blessé
en faisant du skateboard et qu'il a fallu
que je l'amène rapidement chez le médecin.
Ou alors cet hiver,
quand j'ai dévalé la pente de ski,
à plat ventre
la tête en avant.
Mon calme intérieur
et mon efficacité pour gérer
ces situations
m'ont moi-même surprise.
C'est totalement nouveau.
Je n'avais jamais connu en fait
ce calme intérieur.
Ce travail avec la pleine conscience que
j'ai commencé il y a deux ans maintenant
m'a changée profondément.
En fait, je suis devenue moi-même,
sans mes réactions anxieuses
et mon stress.
Les neuroscientifiques appellent ça
la plasticité cérébrale.
Moi, ce que je constate,
c'est que ma joie de vivre est là
et qu'elle reste quoi qu'il arrive.
Et aujourd'hui,
quand je regarde mes enfants,
je vois simplement mes enfants,
ou plutôt aujourd'hui,
mes adolescents,
vautrés sur le canapé du salon.
Vous aussi,
trouvez votre méthode,
trouvez celle qui vous convient,
pour qu'ensemble on fasse bouger
les lignes de ces satanées statistiques.
C'est important parce que
ces méthodes sont préventives.
Selon le plan cancer,
40% des cas sont liés
à des facteurs innés --
pardon --
sont liés à des facteurs évitables,
qui sont dûs à nos modes de vies
et à nos comportements.
Vous savez,
j'ai un rêve.
Je rêve d'un pays --
Je rêve d'un pays
où les managers et les employés
dans les entreprises,
développeraient ensemble
leurs capacités à l'attention.
Un pays où les conseils des ministres
ou les séances de l'assemblée nationale
commenceraient
par dix minutes de calme et de silence.
Et si demain nos enfants, à l'école,
cultiveraient
leur intelligence émotionnelle,
non pas leur QI mais leur QE.
Imaginez l'évolution de notre société
en une génération.
Je vous remercie beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)